High interest on the phones today at (617)
830-4750
go. Uh, let's go to our favorite Israeli color
bow Oz in New Jersey. Bo Oz. What's new with
you?
Hey David, I'm just wanting to call it Israeli.
No, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. But your, your
name is a very popular name in Israel.
Really? Oh, okay. Um, no, no, no. I thought
it was, I thought it was a popular in India.
I didn't know is Israeli.
Oh, okay. Very good.
Yeah. And I've only met, I've only met one
person in the United States with the same
name as me. That was in San Francisco. Crazy.
Um, so I'm calling today, uh, just wanted
to get your opinion on, um, libertarian auditors.
Uh, there seems to be a pretty large community
on YouTube and I'm wondering if you have followed
that by any chance.
No, not at all. Can you tell me about it?
Yeah, so, um, essentially these are, you know,
libertarian, uh, I'm going to left. Um, and
they essentially, uh, check the government,
you know, so they go out to public buildings
and they, um, and you know, they practice
their rights to record and to do this or that.
And they usually do this as a practice to
catch, um, you know, uneducated, you know,
uh, officers or law enforcement, um, who don't
quite know the law.
Oh.
It's kind of an educational tool.
Yeah. So is this similar to the people that
deliberately go to like the border patrol
checkpoints and assert that they don't have
to provide any ID or they go to, um, uh, you
know, sobriety checkpoint? Like there's people
that seek out conversations and confrontations
with law enforcement to film it and then put
it on YouTube?
Yes. Yeah. And it's, it's, it's quite similar.
Got it. Listen, my view is, I find, I'll get
to, I'll answer your question more specifically,
but I find it pretty entertaining to watch
those, but I also find it to be kind of a
sad waste of time for the people doing it.
Right. Well, um, I guess there is an argument
there that it is, uh, it could be a waste
of time, but there was actually a story yesterday.
Um, uh, there is a, a YouTuber, um, auditor,
a blind man, uh, his YouTube channels, blind
justice. He actually, uh, uh, you, uh, cameras
as an assisted device. Um, you know, because
he goes back home and you know, places where
he goes usually by himself. He had his wife
review them and she gives him information
on the places he's been. Um, but he also uses
it to, uh, try to, you know, um, practice
his rights to use a camera and to go to public
places. Um, well it turns out that he went
in, uh, Guilford, uh, new North Carolina.
He, um, went into a public health, uh, office
and he was actually, uh, like assaulted and
battered and taken to the hospital, uh, by
security guard, um, who refused to identify
himself. And it was kinda crazy. I was just,
uh, that's just, uh, it was uploaded automatically
to live stream. So it was really crazy. Um,
I guess the counter argument could be that
I think it's important to, to, uh, show people
like, I don't know, specifics of their rights.
Yeah. Listen, Boaz, here's my thought on this.
I can see it both ways. Like on the one hand,
if people have a right to film and they're
being told they can't film, that's wrong,
and we should make sure that people know,
know the policy and all of that stuff. And,
and I, I've totally respect that. And I'm
with that at the same time being known for
like, Hey, I went to a public health building
and they didn't let me film but I uploaded
it. So now everybody knows that you can film
there. I feel like there are bigger fish to
fry. There's lower hanging fruit. I don't
know. It's hard for me to get too fired up
about like that's the issue. If you go in
North Carolina to the public health building,
you damn well be able to better be able to
film like I get it, but at the same time,
it's not how I would spend my activism. A
M a capital so to speak.
Okay.
Right. No, of course. And um, last point or
uh, yeah, last point.
Mm,
right. Uh, just give me a sec.
Mm.
I think, I think, I think it's an, it's actually
a of an important, uh, connection to make,
you know, because I feel like a lot of these
libertarian auditors are come from, uh, the
right side of, you know, politics, you know,
are generally conservative, but they can share
a lot of the same, um, opinions about police
officers and law enforcement and, you know,
local city officials, you know, that may be,
um, certain communities, like black communities,
like as a black man, like in New Jersey. Uh,
you know, I, I see the kind of distaste as
a black man in a white suburb that police
officers have towards me. You know, if I were
to go around,
hold on a second, Paul. POAs you're, you're
a black man. Yeah.
Yes.
I've never heard of anyone named boas who
was black. That's interesting. And you're
saying your family is Indian?
No, no, no, no, no, no. Uh, I've, uh, I'm
a mixed, I come from a mixed family, um, uh,
a mixed adoptive family, a middle names, Hebrew
Shalom, uh, German, West African, native American,
whole lots of stuff.
Okay, well listen, here's the here. So I think
what you're pointing out is this, the S the
S, um, social libertarians, uh, often are,
are on the left and the right, there's a lot
of overlap in social civil, libertarian ism
from left to right. It's on economic libertarian
is, excuse me, where left and right. Tend
to, um, to, to sort of split off. Uh, but
yes, you're absolutely right that there can
be an Alliance there. Boaz, I, I appreciate
the call. I hope to hear from you again. I'm
going to move on cause I have a lot of people
holding.